Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and we're in the final stretch of the expert levels of Super Mario Maker,
and then maybe, JUST maybe, I can lay this challenge to rest.
Whoah.
Whoah!
Who- Ahh, I was supposed to ride that,
I was supposed to ride that.
That was I supposed to do.
OHHHHHHHHHH
I get it now. I get it. I don't know where it's gonna take me from here, but I'm going to stay on this,
'cause I'm a good boy.
Do it to me! Woooo!
WHAAATTT???
I didn't know the tops of those things were slippery!
Unless Mario is greasing up his feet-
Okay, 38 lives left.
It's really down to the wire here...
I mean, it may seem like a lot, but considering
I lost 20 lives on one level before...
I'm not gonna take any chances.
I'm not gonna take aaaaaaany chances!
WOOOO!!!
WOOOOO!
WOOOOO! Boink!
k
Do me-Do me again! Do me again!
(groans) I know the feeling!
Just thinking about my potential for failure
here is really giving me...
Giving me... (sigh) What was- what'd Danny call it?
(game sounds) "help me"
Whaaaat? What'd you say? "Love you"?
I don't wanna! I don't wanna do
any of that... I don't wanna do anything with that, good God.
OHHHHHH!!!! I GOT AN EASY ONE!!!
Ohhhh YEAH!
OHHHHH!!! Thank you, thank you! THANK YOU, THANK YOU GAME!
THANK YOU!
OHHHHHHHHH
OHHHHHH
YAAAAAAAY!
Oh, yay!
okay! That's good!
2 lives- 2 levels left!
I'M GONNA MAKE IT GUYS! UNLESS THE LAST ONE IS A BITCH!
Whoa that don't look good
I don't know what to do about that- HOLY SHIT!
OH GAWD!!
Okay here we go- Oh god that's not what I wanted!
That's not what I wanted...
Okay, I'm alive! I got a spring...
I don't know if this is what I was supposed to do
What the fuck is going on up here?!
What is this shit? (cough)
Thank you!
Thank you for this!
I'M GONNA GROUND POUND
EEUUUUUGGGHHHH
Okay I though it was about to lie to me-
OH! FUCK! WAUUUGGGHH!!!
OH-FUCHEAUGHAJUBAHAAAYYYYY
Ah shit...
Okay...
Gonna take this...
Heep!!
Thank you
Get, get! get... Thank you
Okay...
Whoa whoa whoa whoa!- What're you doin'...
That's not fair!
Oh, I know how to do this-
Hup!!!
YEA YEA YEAY!!!
oh that... what the
But that... But that... but
But that... but....
Buttathithin
UUUGGHH
HUP!
AGGGHHHH! FUCK OH GOD EXACTLY WHAT I DIDN'T WANT!!!!!
AUUUUGGGGHHHHH!
GOD!!!
OOOOHHH!!! I KNEW IT'S NOT THAT BAD BUT IT STILL HURTS GUUUYYYSS!!!!
GUUUUUYS! IT STILL HUUUUURTS!!!
MY FFFFFFFFEELINGS..
Awww, what a load 'a..
butt blast.
What a butt blasting-
Oh, god damnit..
If I'm not going fast enough--
aHHH FUCK
Okay, so I just gotta take this a-runnin'..
Okay, we got it.
We got it, okay.
And I'm gonna get a mush here..
It's all gonna be good..
I can just drop down here..
Nooo biggie.
Go through the turtle area..
'Cause the turtle area seems to be the winner
Just wait for them to finish their crap.
Almost done.
You gonna..
Okay, good.
nup- FUCK
AGAIN with the- AAAGGH I GOTTA WAIT
AGAINN!!
Okay.
Ah shit.
waahh- FF-
FUCK
urrraahh fuck you
eh!
hhhup
okay.
S- Set you down here, just in case.
Just in case things go wrong.
eeh!
okay.
Things are probably not gonna go wrong..
But I always like to plan for the worst!
hup
uaaa FUCK
don't do tha-
ngahh
ok
Just-
nuh!
AAH THERE'S TWO?!
nuhh fuck yeah okay
Good thing I left this-
Oh, they're all back
Well that's good.
Big ol' bag of dicks.
How many more we got?
ehh
There we go
YEAAH!!
Hoh..
Yesss!
And I get some 1-ups!!
Wooo!!
I'm goin' to the last level with 40 LIVES!!
40 LIVES!!!
OHHH MY GOD--
I'm gonna do it guys
OhhhhHHHHHHHH
I'm so happy
I really am very happy guys
It's been a good day!!
Thi- This whole session started off a little wonky, but--
Here we go, 40 lives for the last level.
I can do- ohhh GOD NOO
OHH GOD NO!!
OHH GOD NOO!!!
NOOOO!!
Okay.
I just gotta get through this
WOW
Who- FU- Okay,
That's fine!
Just went a little too... fast
On that!
IT'S FINE
OH Lordy
If I fail this on the very end here
I knew it was too good to be true, with getting those easy-peasy levels
Oh, THAT'S coming over for me
THAT'S gonna touch me in the bumbum
AHH. GOOD!
Okay. It's going to be fine
cause I know how to beat this
UUAARGH MAN the momentum is a bitch there.
Man, that momentum is just a sack of shit.
oh man, if this castle was just designed a little bit smarter
It wouldn't be such a PILE OF DICKS-
WOAH
WOAH WOAH
Woah. woah.
Okay.
(pant)
Ah, ah WHAAAAAT??!
WHAAAAAATTTTTTTTTT???!!!!
Fuck, oh god I'm already six lives down
Oh, god
I'm getting flashbacks
Ahh- WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED THERE?
WHAT? WHY DIDN'T I GO AS HIGH????
Oh, good Lordy-loo.
Okay.
so I just gotta jump
do do do
Okay, easy-peasy.
I can do this
Simple jumps.
Aw, FU- AW, THE FUCKIN' MOMENTUM HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
FUCK THIS
I mean of course, it gives me two easy ones
because it wants me to have a false sense of security about things
and then
JUST when I'm feeling happy
I just...after I...it's because it's got happiness sensors
and it heard that I was happy, I told you guys I was happy
aw, FUCK. I guess I could spin jump? The left way? Aw, man.
Aw, man.
it's got happiness sensors
and I guess Jojo is an alias for Ross
ok, fuck you
that's the only way that I can think to beat the momentum
is just spin jumping
ahh f- no, how? How are you supposed to do that?
seriously, how?
like, what?!
h- how are you supposed to do that?
I'm disheartened because I...what?
guys, it's not fair
guys, it's not fair!
oh f-, that was my fault, but, wow. What?! Are you kidding me?
IT'S NOT FAIR! What the fuck?
ugh, ok, ok
ok
I don't want- I don't want whatever's down there
whatever's down there is not worth it. This seems like it was made by a Ross-type
this, this level seems like, just fucking Ross all over it
it's wa- oh,  what the f- no, what the fuck happened?
what the fuck was that?
what?!
are you kidding me?
oh my god
why did that happen?
ok
so far so goo
I can just run across here
ok, oh that is, that is just dicketry
that is just dicketry
you fucking asshole
whoever made this level is a goddamn asshole
AH FUCK COME ON MAN, FUCK OFF!
it's, it's not fair. After every-
it's not fair
oh no, 24 lives left. 24 lives left. Are you kidding me?
I can't waste a single one
I cannot waste a single one
ugh, you, ugh, I can't see that. I can't
are you kidding me? I don't know that's there!
fuck off!
20 lives left. 20 lives left
no, wha- man. What the hell? What the hell, man?
Criminy christmas..
I did the shortest-
AHHHHHH FFFF. I'm nah, no, no, NO!
this is bullshit, fuck that level!!
I'M NOT LETTING IT TAKE IT AWAY FROM ME. I HAVE COME TOO FAR. I HAVE DONE TOO MUCH
(fart sound)
I don't care what you show me. I don't care what you do
I will not be fucked over. I will not
be fucked over
I refuse to be fucked over
I refuse it
I refuse. I will not... I will not
I will not
okay.
I'm okay.
no
NOOO
You random chance piece of shit!
if that's what you're gonna make this level about, then fuck you!
AHHHH F-
ok, we're getting back to this one
if it's- if it's another random chance, I'm skipping this level too because holy shit
it better not be
it-
(replaying as if in own head) I'M NOT LETTING IT TAKE IT AWAY FROM ME, I HAVE COME TOO FAR
(replaying) I HAVE DONE TOO MUCH. I WILL NOT BE FUCKED OVER...BUTTBLAST
ugh, fuck off, yes, yes, yes, YES, YES, YES, YES!
YES! YEAH! AHHHHHH! AAAAHHHH!
ugh
hooooh
oh
there's everyone who contributed to the levels, probably even the ones that I skipped
I minorly regret that I had to skip the last one
but I just didn't want to fail. I was heartbroken
I was heartbroken at the end there
I was just feeling sorrow in the pit of my soul. It was bad
it was bad
but we did it
I'm just gonna be very clear
I don't think I'm ever gonna do the super...oh it's only 6 levels
ok, maybe then, but I don't think so for now
I think I've played Mario Maker for a long time now and I've accomplished something that I wanted to do
I do feel good that I got through that and holy shit
you saw, I was trying hard on that last one but man, I was not good enough at wall jumps
wall jumps are like my one weakness and goddamn it of course in the last level there's some random chance
but thankfully it wasn't more than that and I got through that
perfectly
(sigh) I've never concentrated so hard in my life
so thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for sticking with me through this entire time
thank you for supporting me through the entire journey that I took on Super Mario Maker
thank you for being there with me in the ragiest moments
and the happiest joyous successes
thank you so much for being here with me the whole way through
this has been...a fucking ride
but thank you guys, so I'm really, I seriously am very grateful for you guys
for joining me here. It has been a wild ride
I don't know if I'm gonna try super expert
cause I don't know if my heart can take it
but thank you guys again so much for watching and thank you for enjoying it
I really hope you did, let me know if you did in the comments below
and thanks again.
and as always, I will see you in the next video!
Bye-bye!!
(outro music)